called Bam Bam on a budget. You can do
it. Um I gave this talk recently at
Hardware IO. Um I wasn't even planning
on giving a talk as you'll see, but um
but this is the story of that. So it's
more the story of hacking into an
automotive ECU. Um and then we'll get
into some of the technical details kind
of as we go. And then um any questions
you have uh I'll just kind of pause on
each one and I'll I'll check the chat
here real quick and I'll see you know is
everything clear. So feel free to pop
stuff in and then I'll hang around at
the end and uh we can just go through
anything that you feel like I missed or
it wasn't clear when I was explaining it
or or you know anything like that. So
let's get rolling.
Okay. So late last year, someone reached
out to me and they said they had a job
they wanted me to work on to hack into
this MPC5566
chip that's used in automotive ECUs. I
didn't know who they were. I didn't know
anything about them. Uh I never met
them. Um and after the job was done, I
just wiped all communication. So this
was kind of one of those like somebody
reached out to you is like, "Hey, can
you break into this thing for And I
thought it would be an interesting
challenge.
Now, why would somebody do that? Why
would someone reach out to me? Now,
everybody that's here, you know, well, I
have a YouTube channel, right? Um, and I
show all kinds of things on there about
glitching microchips and breaking into
things. And most of it's all smart meter
related. That's where I kind of focus my
efforts. Um, just because it's a fun
target to attack, but I'm interested in
attacking all kinds of things. Um, and
so that's that's what led to this person
reaching out to me.
Now, when they reached out, they sent
over this document and it's written by
Colin Flynn. It's called BAM Bam, you
know, on the reliability of
electromagnetic fault injection for
attacking automotive ECUs. Um, and I
kind of looked at this as like my user
manual essentially. Like, yeah, I'm
going to break into this chip, but
there's a manual. Like, this guy wrote a
manual for how to do this. So, how hard
could it really be if I have a whole
book? And he published videos and and
everything else showing how to do it.
Now, the attack overall is fairly
simple. So all you have, you know, in
the end is the ECU that you're going to
attack. You're going to connect to it
over like a a serial connection. So
you're going to basically talk to it
back and forth and you're going to blast
the crap out of it with EMP. Like that's
the summary of the whole attack. Like it
it feels kind of deceptively simple,
which is probably why uh I accepted this
thing.
Now, uh, the way you talk to this thing,
it's called a boot access module. Um,
and it's like a a kind of a bootloadader
type of device inside the processor. So,
the bootloadader itself um, you
basically send it's got this kind of
communication system. So, if you're
talking to it over the UR, the first
thing you do is you send the password to
it. So, it's got a password. It can be
set or it cannot be set. Um, and so you
send each character of the password and
then it echoes those characters back to
you. If your password's correct, then it
accepts the address you want to store
your data you're going to send and then
how much data you're going to send. Then
the next thing is sending all of that
data. Um, and then if if all that's
correct and good, it will run your code.
So you can think of like the boot access
module as like this little piece of code
that's running inside the processor and
all it's going to do is take uh kind of
a program you write that you send it and
if everything's good it will execute
that program. Generally in my case that
program was to dump all the flash memory
that was in the chip. But there isn't
kind of a a you know a thing you enter
to just extract the memory. So you have
to write this program and go through
this communication kind of thing.
Now uh if you're going to do it over the
canvas, it's very similar. The
difference is when you do it over the
UART, you send one me like one bite at a
time and it echoes one bite at a time
back to you. So you get like more
granular feedback I would say when you
send your messages. That's part of the
attack. That part will become kind of a
little little clearer later. It was a
key part of how they did the timing.
When you do the CAN bus, um the CAN bus,
you have to send your whole message and
if your whole message is correct, then
it echoes back your whole message, but
using a different um ID number. So the
CAN, they all have this kind of like CAN
ID. So you send an 11, it echoes back a
one, you send a 12, it echoes back a
two, but otherwise the whole process is
essentially the same.
So, what do I see? It's my fault there's
a rise in car thefts. It's possible it
could be my my fault that's a rise in
smart meter hacking. You know, what are
you going to do, right? Everybody
figures this stuff out. It gets more
secure if you just share it with the
whole world and show kind of how
insecure it is.
Okay. So, I should say something here
that like um I got a little frustrated
working on this thing. Um and so I might
say things throughout the course of this
thing that is like uh might seem like
I'm attacking Colin. Um you know, let's
be clear, I like Colin. Colin's a cool
dude. Colin's done way more for the
reverse engineering community than I've
done. Um, so anything I say is more out
of the frustration of reverse
engineering and less about Colin, you
know, it's probably my own my own crap
and struggle. Um, so let's I just wanted
to put that out there because uh I think
he's awesome and I think everything he's
done is awesome and I literally use his
tools to do this attack. So if he didn't
exist, this wouldn't exist.
Now, this board that I got that somebody
sent me, um, there was nothing published
about it and I told them that I wouldn't
share anything about the board that I
worked on for them, what it was from,
anything like that. Um, so everything in
this presentation, all the pictures
you'll see are actually from a different
ECU that uses the same MPC 5566 chip.
Um, the board that I got, there was only
one of them available. So, when I
initially started, I was attacking this
basically one board that if something
goes wrong with it, like that's it.
There's only one copy of it. Um, later
on, I did get a second one um because I
needed to kind of, you know, remove the
BGA chip and look at pins underneath it.
Um, and so they did give me a second
board that was just dead, but that I
could then remove parts and and kind of
figure out connections a little easier
than just pure kind of guessing.
Now, step one, um, is just to identify
the pins you need. Um, so on this board,
um, I had kind of taken a a best guess,
but then when I got the second one, I
popped the BGA chip off of it, just kind
of heat gunned it, and I wasn't too
worried about like the survival of the
BGA chip because like the whole board's
dead anyway. So, I heat gunned the whole
thing, removed that chip, and there's
four pins you're basically looking for
that are outlined in Colin's paper.
Those four pins are the TXDA and RXDA,
which are just transmit and receive to
the UART. Um, a boot config pin. This is
the pin you set high or low that makes
it enter this kind of BAM mode. It's
brought out on these specific chips.
Newer versions of this chip, um, later
kind of families that came out, they
removed like the, you know, they they
have like a setting where the external
pin won't be uh, what would you call it?
like you have a way to disable this
external pin so someone can't just force
you into a boot mode and attack you. Um
but these chips that's not the case.
Like you can just force them into this
boot mode and try to break in. Um and
then the reset line so you can control
resets. So on the BGA chip that's that
red box that's there where they're kind
of um all in this area conveniently.
Now, one way I I like to basically tone
out kind of pins when you don't know
where the heck they are is this kind of
like broom method I call it. And so, you
just get a bunch of copper and you you
spread it out. This was some I think
like welding cable I had in the garage.
Um, but anything like coax shielding or
something like that. And you just do the
drag method across the board until you
hear a tone. And then when you hear a
tone, then you kind of go and you zoom
in the area. So think of it as like a a
kind of you know wide wide way to scan
it.
Now the this you know the the summary
here the summary here that's from
Colin's paper is that the attack on this
module assumes that we have external
control of this boot config pin which
will force us into this boot mode.
So this looks like this. So, this is
what it's supposed to look like when
it's working. The little red characters
you see there are me sending data over
the UART to the ECU and yellow is it
responding and the other yellow is just,
you know, some kind of garbage or
something that it's spitting out until I
send a character. Um, so this is how
it's supposed to work. Every character
you send, it echoes it back. It echoes
it back as long as what you're sending
is correct. So, I send 1 through 8 as
the password. That's not correct. So,
then it stops echoing my characters,
which you can see me sending here, the
red uh characters.
Now, uh the challenge I had with my
board is that no matter what I sent to
it, uh it didn't send anything back.
So, I would send characters, but I was
never receiving anything uh no matter
what I did.
I watched all of Colin's, you know,
videos. I'd read the paper, all this
stuff. Um, and so then I opened up, um,
what turns out to be my Bible for the
next, uh, the next many, many days,
which turn into weeks, uh, which turn
into months. Um, and this, uh, this
Bible is about, uh, I don't know, 1,200
pages long, 12 or 1300 pages. And all I
did all day and night was read this
reference manual looking for anything I
could find um that would tell me like
what am I missing? Why are things not
working? Um and I was just, you know, in
it in it literally all day and night.
All I did was search this thing for
little footnotes, something maybe that
was left that I could use.
Now I did go back to my iPad history. So
all the books you open, um, PDFs and
whatnot, it sorts them, you know, based
on, uh, uh, what time you opened it. And
so I thought this was interesting. So in
the middle of working on this thing,
like I was seriously going through it,
uh, you know, I mean, questioning
everything kind of about my life. And
turns out I was reading Man's Search for
Meaning at the same time, which tells
you like, uh, this thing was uh,
freaking really taxing me.
Now, what I discovered in that reference
manual is a thing called reset config.
Um, reset config, you have to control
for it to look at the boot config pin
and actually do something with it. If
you don't control the reset config pin,
nothing will happen. So, this was like,
holy crap. Like, I've been working on
this thing trying to control this pin.
Um, and no wonder I'm not entering any
kind of boot mode. No wonder nothing's
responding.
Now, this is where uh my man here uh
kind of pissed me off a little bit if
I'm being honest. Um, this paper, Bam
Bam, uh, as a fun fact, has 5,928
words in it. Um, and of all those words,
not a single word is reset config. Uh,
and funny enough, in the reference
manual, reset config is mentioned 90
different times. So, uh, you know, the
frustrating part for me was that I'm not
an academic. I'm not a, you know, a PhD.
Um, I read these papers that come out.
They're very interesting to me. And uh
you know what I expected like I guess
my expectation was that these papers are
meant to allow you to replicate what is
in them. Like I thought that was the
point of scientific papers is that you
know other people can replicate what's
in them and then you build upon it,
right? I don't know how you could
replicate what's in this if you don't
control the reset config pin. Like it's
impossible. Um, and and there's four
different boards that you know Colin
shows using in this paper. Um, and those
boards like you would have had to
control the reset config pin on them
like so how this got missed, how it
didn't end up in the paper, how it
didn't get caught like during any kind
of review or anything like is kind of
like mind-blowing to me. But it's
possible it just wasn't caught. I mean,
my my kind of mind went to like, oh, I
bet, you know, the the companies told
him not to include certain details. Um,
but most people I talked to were just
like, no, man. You know, it just got
missed. Like, that's probably what
happened.
Now, um, there's kind of some more bad
news. So, I discover this reset config
thing. Um, I get it set. I set the boot
config, all of that. Um, but no matter
what I do, the the transmit line that's
coming from this chip just sits at one
volt. It does not like I don't see
anything coming from it. Um, no matter
what I do, like I'm sure at this point
like all my modes are set, everything's
right. I don't have any other boards to
verify it against, but I mean, you know,
I've literally been reading the spec
sheet for like days and days at this
point. Like I I know it's I know it's
right. There's something something
doesn't feel right. Like why is the
transmit pin just sitting like that now?
I'm not sure like you know if the re if
the the receive line is still working.
So like I'm sending data to it. I'm
trying like a zillion different baud
rates like just trying to figure out
what's going on. Um but I'm getting no
response. Like that echo you saw with
those yellow characters is not coming
back for me.
So you know a bit of a an update. I
literally quoted five days to complete
this job in retrospect. Uh
that's like that's probably psychotic.
Um because I had never done a ton of the
stuff that's in this. So to think that
I'm going to get this board that I've
never seen before and perform this
attack that I've never done before using
some tools that I've never used before
um and some tools that I don't even have
in 5 days. Um you know is kind of
ludicrous. Um, so at this point I'm 10
days into the fiveday job and I
discovered the UART's dead. The UART is
my exfiltration point to get my data
out. So I'm like screwed screwed at this
point. Like I can't how am I even going
to get the data out and I'm I'm already
double the amount of time that I've
quoted to do this uh freaking job,
right?
Um, but Colin, you know, in his paper,
he does talk about the canvas quite a
bit. Can versus UART. Um, and he talks
about like, okay, you know, maybe you
could use the canvas. He never says he's
tried the canvas. He never says the CAN
bus will actually work. Um, he just says
like, okay, you know, the canvas is
another way.
So, I I start to think like, "Oh man,
maybe Colin's my savior after all." Um,
and he's he's come to me with a new
method that I can try considering the
UART on the board that I'm trying to
extract this data from is dead.
So, it's kind of like what to do at this
point. Um, you know, I don't want to use
the canvas. Like, if I'm being honest,
you know, like I don't want to come up
with some whole new attack that's
completely undocumented. Like, I'm just
trying to do this job and get paid, you
know, like I could use some cash. So,
um, I reach out and I just say, "Hey, do
you have another board?" Um, and so I'm
waiting to hear back to kind of see
like, is there another board? Can I
just, you know, test another one of
these? and I realized like, oh, I don't
I don't actually know anything about
EMPing a board. Like, I have this Pico
EMP, um, but I've kind of like never
really done anything with it, so I
should probably spend some time learning
about that.
Um, but there's something that is like a
main point
um that I think uh I should bring up
here, which is like when you read
Colin's paper, it's very specific. Like
one, he's using a chip shouter. Um that
device is like $4,000. I'm using a Pico
EMP which is $50. Um so there's a you
know like an order of magnitude
difference in the the product that I'm
using to attack this. He's very
specific. He uses 444 volts to pulse
this thing. So, I don't know anything
other than 444 volts is stuck in my
head. Um,
now why does that matter?
It's because the Pico EMP only goes up
to 250 volts and the chip shouter goes
up to 500 volts. So, uh, you know, I'm
not I'm not completely convinced that if
I buy a chip shouter, it'll work. Um,
but I'm also not sure that if I use the
Pico EMP, it'll work. But, you know, I
kind of start to think and I'm like,
well, if you're going to spend all the
time and effort to write one of these
papers, like, it's a lot of work, and
attack all these boards and get this
stuff, like, if you're Colin, would you
try to sell your $4,000 device or would
you try to sell your $50 device? And I'm
like, he's a smart dude, you know, he's
a businessman. It's like, might as well,
you know, make sure that the range of
what you're using is for the high-end
device.
Now, this here is a very good summary of
what I had done up until uh I kind of
took on this job with a Pico EMP. Um, I
would just point it at stuff. I would
press the little button and I would see
stuff reboot. I'm like, "Oh man, look at
that. I'm freaking emping the crap out
of this thing." Um, which is not the
controlled kind of setup that I need to
actually cause a fault which will allow
me access to extract memory. So, I'm not
even sure like,
you know, how do I send an external
trigger because I have to control this
from like a chip whisperer or something
else that is going to watch all the
signals on the the main board and then
determine when to, you know, send the
glitch and then send that signal to the
Pico EMP so that it can pulse the chip.
Um, how do I even control like the width
of the pulse or the the voltage of the
pulse? Like, I've never done anything
with it. All I've done is literally
press this button and move it around.
Now, this is this is kind of good to
look at these two setups. So, on the
left here
um is a setup that uh is what you would
kind of use in these environments. It's
like an XYZ table. You see it's very
precise how it's moving around on the
chip. I mean, you're going to scan like,
you know, the silicon die that's inside
there. Obviously the features are very
small. You know that one on the left can
move it like micrometer you know scale
right across the thing. Um let's
contrast that with what I'm using on the
right. Uh which is a you know
essentially a magnetic clamp that a
machinist would use to hold like a a
gauge against you know something on a
lathe to to measure runout or whatever.
Um, and I have my Pico EMP clamped in
it, and I'm just kind of scooting the
thing around looking for the right spot.
So, you know, equipment wise, uh, vastly
vastly different. Um, so,
let me let me check the questions here
real quick. Make sure I'm not missing
something you guys are asking.
How does one charge money for this? Um,
you guess a well, I guessed a fixed
amount and I quoted it. Uh probably
probably not the the best way to do it,
but if you charge hourly, like someone
would feel like they're getting scammed,
right? Like uh you know, I'm like, well,
I'll just charge it by the hour and I'll
work on it for 6 months. Um you know,
but if you do quote a price, um the risk
is if you don't know what the hell
you're doing, like you just it's, you
know, I I I kept working on it until I
figured it out. Um maybe maybe other
people wouldn't do that, you know. Um,
so yeah, so it can be kind of tough to
quote. Yeah, 4K is a lot for a chip
shouter. I mean, but considering how
much time I spent, um, not sure, uh, you
know, maybe the 4K wasn't that much,
honestly. Um, time time gets eaten up
pretty quick, you know.
Um,
let's see.
Yes, this is a E39A board. Um, there's
E39 and E39A. The one on the right is
E39A. We'll get into why that matters
here in a moment.
So, this was something interesting I
discovered um that I felt was like I
probably didn't expand on this enough
during my hardware IO talk, but I am
going to expand on it a bit here. So,
let's look at this thing real quick.
again the one on the left. The way you
generally profile
um how to find like a glitch using an
EMP thing is you would take the chip
probably on a development board like
what you see there on the left. You
would write some code. So the code would
be like a loop that's running and and
the loop is just like a a forever loop.
So while one um you know increment a
counter or do something and so the loop
should never escape. Um, but if the loop
does escape for some reason, then you
would print out something else and maybe
go back to your main loop. What you then
do with the fault injection setup is you
start inserting faults and you scan all
across the chip and you see where do I
cause that main loop to break out which
should never happen because it's just a
forever wild kind of loop. You then have
kind of these points you determine where
the chip is vulnerable. you you try
different voltages and so you profile
the chip basically and you find where
can I attack it to cause a fault. Um I
didn't have that right like I had the
one board the dude gave me with the code
that's running on it that needs to come
out. So I can't do any of this
profiling. So um what I discovered was
purely by accident. Like it's not some
super genius move. probably the genius
was or or you know the the smart thing I
did was watching the oscilloscope and
thinking like oh that's interesting
maybe I could use that somehow. Um but
this wasn't some pre kind of genius
thing.
So what it is is there's a pin on the
chip called clock out and all clock out
does is take whatever clock the chip is
running at and it spits it out. Um, and
when you glitch the chip, what I would
see is that that clock would actually
change a bit. It would kind of stutter
and it would change frequency from like
12 MHz to 16 and then back down. Um, and
if I glitched it too hard, the clock
would actually just drop out. The line
would go low. Now, I discovered this
because what I was trying to do was
synchronize my chip whisperer. So the
chip whisperer is what's you know
basically watching everything that's
going to go on uh coordinate the sending
of messages and all these things
glitch the chip um and then you know
watch the output um and so ideally you
synchronize like the chip whisper with
the clock that's running on the board so
every time you hit it it's some certain
clock cycle it's like exacting because
those things are both synchronized
together. So, my idea was I'll take this
clock out, I'll feed it into the chip
whisperer, and I'll use that as my
clock, and then I know everything's
synchronized. When I tried to do that,
the chip whisperer was just freaking out
all the time. Um, and so I started
looking at this clock out on the
oscilloscope, and then what I noticed
was like, oh man, it's falling out or
it's doing these weird things. Um, but
then I put the uh picomp into a mode
where I'm just kind of sending pulses.
And so I would just move that little
thing across the board. And when I would
see this clock output start to freak out
um or go to reset, I knew, okay, I'm in
the right spot and maybe I need to
adjust my settings. And if I adjust my
settings just to cause the clock to kind
of stutter a bit like it's doing here
versus completely fall out, I'm in the
right spot. So I don't need to write any
code. I don't need to make that loop to
scan the chip or anything else. I can
just use pure hardware to look at this.
A lot of chips have clock outputs like
this. So, it's a very good way, like a
no code kind of way to just watch this
thing on an oscilloscope, move your
probe around, and when you get in the
right spot, you basically got a a
complete indicator right there.
All right. How does one learn how to
work on electrical boards? Um, I mean,
you just do it. like I spent like a long
long time just the way you learn is um
be comfortable being incredibly
frustrated
and thinking you don't know what you're
doing uh and thinking this is complete
crap and you'll never figure it out and
then just don't stop ever. And if you do
that you you just like you you'll become
good at anything. Um, you know, because
all you'll do is spend all day and night
trying to focus on how to figure this
thing out that you've determined you
want to figure out. For me, that's it.
Like that's how I do it. Other people,
you maybe you go to school, you go to a
class, whatever. Um, I'm not sure. But
for me, it's just like work on it and
obsess over it. Um, and do not let it go
until you figure it out.
Okay?
But in the back of my mind, like, is
this 444 volts? Like, okay, I'm doing
this. I'm causing these faults, but
like, is it enough? I don't know. I've
never done it before. Um, and all that I
can think about is like, you know, is it
enough? I even did so much as like I
went on to Digi Key, um, and I ordered
parts to try to convert my Pico EMP to
500 volts. So I have, you know, kind of
these parts sitting on the side that
like if I get stuck, here's a MOSFET
that's rated higher. Here's a capacitor
that's rated higher, some diodes, kind
of the parts of the circuit because the
Pico MP is open source. So you can see
all the the schematic. So I was like,
okay, if I shift these parts around and
cluge something together, um, if I need
to, I can get to 500 volts.
Now, um the other thing that's important
in this setup is the coils. Um so when
you're doing like voltage glitching, all
you're doing is, you know, basically
controlling the the voltage that goes to
the chip. So you're dropping it down or
whatever. When you're doing EMP
glitching, you have like uh many more
variables, right? You have the variable
of like where is it on the chip. um you
have the variable of how big is the
coil, how many turns is the coil, is the
coil wound clockwise or
counterclockwise. That is the one thing
that definitely I've seen make a
difference. But one of the cool things
about going to hardware IO was I met a
guy named Christopharro. Um I've tweeted
some stuff recently of talks he's done.
This guy um is like the uber genius of
um EMP glitching and any paper, anything
he puts out, that's what you know you
should look at. is like if you want to
do this like mine my stuff I think is
like it's cool to maybe get you
interested right you're like oh that
looks interesting uh I'm not a
definitive source like these are this is
kind of like what worked for me um his
stuff is like what I go read now I
talked to that guy for 30 minutes I feel
like I advanced my knowledge by like an
entire year um so that's a cool reason
if you're thinking about going to these
conferences like it's definitely worth
it to chat with people um because you
can learn a lot here what you is I have
some different size ferites. This is
just basically ferite rods that are on
the left there that I'm winding that
wire around. Um the size of it is just
kind of going to control the size of
your pulse. I ended up going with like a
3 mm. Um and it's the only one I tested.
So smaller might have worked, larger
might have worked. I don't know. I wound
only like four coils around it because
my kind of thought was like my voltage
isn't as high. So, if my voltage isn't
as high, I just want to try to um not
have a coil with so many windings
because you might need a higher voltage
for that. Um, and one thing that I did
notice is because my setup is all kind
of lower voltage, lower power compared
to a a chip shouter, getting that coil
as close to the processor as possible
does make a difference. Um, and we'll
see kind of like the silicon in the
package of the chip is also down a
little bit. So, you know, you you're
working with distance and and things are
falling off at the, you know, the it's
exponential, right? So, the the square,
you know, the square root or whatever of
the the thing is how stuff is falling
off that pulse. So, you're losing energy
really fast as your distance increases.
Now, so I I just sanded that's like a
granite surface plate that's down there,
but even a piece of glass with some
sandpaper on it, you sand that coil and
get it as close as possible.
Now, one thing that I realized is I
needed to control the voltage of this
thing. Like I need some variable. So
location is a variable. And technically,
you could kind of think as like the
Z-axis, like even if I didn't change the
voltage, if I just moved it up a little
bit, that is also kind of probably the
same effect. It might not be because
it's like how is this pulse coming out?
Um, but you know it might be but I don't
have fine Z control like you saw my
setup. Like there's nothing precise
about that setup. So my plan was just
plant the thing right on top of the
chip. So my Z control is I'm just
sitting on the chip and then I'm just X
and Y are my variables and maybe I can
adjust the voltage somehow. So there's a
little cover normally on the uh where is
it? Let's see if I can show you this.
Here you go.
There's a little cover normally on the
uh the chip shout or the the pico EMP
here, this little red cover and it says
don't remove because there's high
voltage. So the first thing I did is uh
I removed that and that's what's
underneath it right there. And it nice
has a little header to plug in and so
you see I'm reading 250 volts from this
thing.
Now, the cool thing about the the Pico
EMP is it does have um like this kind of
whole serial style interface. So,
there's a USB port on it and you can
actually control stuff that's there. Um
and one of them lets you set the pulse
power and the pulse time. Um the pulse
time didn't seem to matter at all, but
the power was what I was interested in.
Um, but it's set in this freaking really
weird way of like I think you're
defining like the the pulsewidth
modulation value in some sense. Um, so
what I did was I would send these
different values like 05. So the first
value in that table says 50, 05. I would
send 05 and I would measure on the uh
voltmeter what voltage am I getting. Um,
and then I would send you know another
value and what voltage and what voltage.
So I built this little table um that's
like a conversion table.
Then what I did was um I found someone's
interpolation code they had written that
basically if you feed in a little table
of values um it will interpolate all the
other values for you. So then instead of
sending these weird, you know, kind of
whatever pulse with modulation values, I
can just say I want to do a pulse
voltage of 100. And this whole thing
will interpolate it and and whatever and
put it across. This is already on a
GitHub, so don't worry about the code
that's here. All of it's posted on
GitHub. Um, you can see it. Um, but this
is super handy if you're going to do
anything with a PCMP. This just makes
the the usage of it in a more kind of uh
Yeah. in a in a better kind of
controlled type of attack you want to do
versus just the little button press and
stuff like that.
I'll take a look at comments real quick.
See if I'm missing anything.
Um, be okay to break crap 100%. Uh,
you're going to break a lot of crap if
you work on hardware. Um, so if you want
to hack things, don't hack things you
can't afford to buy like 10 of. Um,
because you'll buy, you know, easily 10
of them or whatever, especially as
you're getting started.
Um,
it's an accurate description on how to
learn how to do this, that's for sure.
Slap it on a 3D printer. That's what
most people do. They put these little uh
like a Pico EMP on a 3D printer. I might
do that. Um because it would be fun to
run some tests of scanning. So after I
talked to um after I talked to
Christopharo, he said something uh you
know that kind of blew my mind like I
was worried about coils and well what
coil do you use for this and what coil
for that? And he's like I use a freaking
same coil for everything. And he's
attacking crazy stuff like arm trust
zone kind of things and stuff like that.
Um and I was like the same coil? And
he's like, "Yep, one coil." And and he
doesn't even play with the Z-axis. Like,
he scans it around. Because, you know
what he said is like, if you're scanning
around a chip,
where you're actually causing the fault
might not be where you think you're
causing the fault. So, I might be like,
well, you need to place the probe right
here, you know, over the letter M on the
the chip. The fault might actually be
somewhere over to the side. And maybe
the main energy that's focused there as
it's going out it's decreasing, right?
And so it might be that over here is
where the fault really is. And so if you
scan the chip, you can kind of see like
as I move around this area, maybe the
fault is kind of in the middle of where
I'm moving around. And so some amount of
that energy is causing something there.
Um, and it was kind of really eye
opening to me because I was I was just
paying attention probably to a lot of
things that weren't going to be the
things that mattered. Um, so yeah, I
think probably doing like an XY table
with a uh a cheapy little uh 3D printer
or something is probably an interesting
next thing to do if I was going to
attack more stuff. Um, although I mean
once you're able to find the spot and
whatever, it's surprisingly easy using
that crappy little setup that I got or
whatever, you know.
Okay. So, this is just um a little video
that kind of summarizes that stuff. So,
you see I have it hooked up here. It's
basically reading 250 volts. Um this is
the pulsewidth modulation that is uh is
going inside there. So, inside the
picomp to charge the capacitor, there's
this little PWM thing that is running
that charges the capacitor to a
different value. So this is like uh I
think 10 microsconds per division and
you saw it was probably like an 8
microcond pulse that it's off. Um but
then as I adjust that pulse we see the
voltage changes. Um so now I can set it
to about 50 volts. Um and the pulse is a
different width. Um and I'll go over to
the computer here. I'll type in another
uh another little voltage value here on
the screen. Um so I was doing 50 there.
Um, and the the width of the pulse is
probably the off time would be my guess,
which is why it got longer and then uh,
you know, the voltage went down. And so
I set it to 100. It's within like plus
or minus, you know, a volt or two. So,
you know, it's pretty pretty darn
accurate for being as kind of uh, you
know, lowfi as it is. Each board you
might have to profile separately.
Um, but you know, in the back of my
head, right, like, okay, 250 volts,
voltage control, all this crap, but is
it going to be enough? Like, is all this
for nothing? Um, that that number just
tortured the hell out of me.
So, I get a message back um from the
mystery person and they say, "That's the
only board I have." And so I'm like,
crap. You know, um, and I'm thinking
crap because like, was this dead when I
got it? Did I do something that caused
it to die? Like, I don't know. I don't
have any way of knowing. Um, all I know
is that the UART isn't working. So, um,
because there's that uncertainty in my
mind, um, I don't just default to, well,
I'm going to send it back. Like say I
had gotten this board and uh the UART
was dead right away and this test was
simple. I'd be like, "Well, hey man, you
got to send me a board with the UART
that works or the price is going up
because I got to build this whole
attack." But I don't know, you know, I
don't know if I did something that
caused the UR to die. Um I don't think I
did. Um but I can't I can't be sure. So,
um, I'd been reading about the canvas
quite a bit over time and so I thought,
okay, maybe I can do it. Now,
I thought maybe I could do it because
I've never done anything with the
canvas. So, I had that great sense of
like when you're completely ignorant
about something and you're like, ah, you
know, I could probably do this. How hard
could it really be? Um, it turns out
it's pretty hard. Um, but I had that
sense in the beginning.
Now, um, if we look at the canvas, to
me, it's like I I looked at I was like,
well, it's kind of just like a UART,
right? Like it's just, you know, it's a
different kind of way of sending data.
Um, but as I was working on it,
um, I would send messages. So, this is
kind of you're looking at the
oscilloscope view of stuff going across
and then, um, the CAN tools on Linux
kind of view of stuff. And I would try
to glitch it. I would send my CAN
password and then the whole bus would
freaking flood with data and just
stuff's coming across. I'm thinking
like, oh man, this is awesome. Like I
glitched this thing and it's just
dumping out all kinds of stuff. Maybe
that's firmware that's flying across.
Like I'm not sure yet. I got to I got to
really take a look at it. But um what I
kind of started to realize is like is
this really coming from the processor or
is my tooling, you know, doing something
weird? And so I started to become less
and less confident that this is the
processor dumping data over the canvas
and more like maybe my tooling is having
some kind of issue.
So um this is how I was sending the
data. So if you're familiar with canvas
um what I was doing is I had these
messages defined. Um so the first
message up there it's a feeface cafe
beef is kind of like a you know the the
standard password for this thing if
there is no password. So I was sending a
public password. I then had a message um
that is you know the the data where it's
going to get loaded um and I would use
this bus send which is what you see at
the bottom there to send that message
um and all I want to do is send one
message right um but sending that one
message completely floods the bus
now that's because if we take a very
close look at this um when you send one
message on the canvas, um the canvas
controller has a really awesome feature.
That feature is that if it doesn't see
this little tiny dip at the end, which
is called an act, uh it will just flood
the freaking bus like crazy until
someone responds to the message. So, it
sends a message, if it doesn't hear a
response, it's just going to go buck
wild until it gets a freaking response
from whatever's there. Um, and so this
is terrible if you're trying to glitch
something because you're literally
causing faults in the chip. So of course
it's not going to respond to these
messages now and not all the time at
least, right? Um, now on the UART, what
was different on the UART is you would
send one bite and then you would get a
one bite echo. And so you could just
send the one bite and then glitch after
the one bite. And with a UART, when you
send one bite, that's all that gets
sent. Uh, not so with the canvas.
So, I kind of took a break um and I
thought, you know, maybe maybe the
freaking canvas isn't going to work. Um,
maybe I should look at JTAG. Um, JTAG
the challenge is you have to get a
separate programmer. So, you can't just
use like open OCD and a standard J-tag
interface for these MPC chips. You need
this thing made by PE Micro. It costs
money. You need software made by PE
Micro. It costs money. So, you have to
kind of invest in this setup, which I
did. Um, the thing I got on eBay, but
the software I just had to buy from the
company. And why I did it was because
reading that kind of forever reference
manual um I saw this chip configuration
register and this thing called a disex
bit which is for disable nexus. Nexus is
the thing you connect to essentially
that gives you JTAG access. So there's
hundreds of these registers that get set
when the the chip boots up.
My thought was maybe I can hit this
register like somehow, right? Like it's
kind of wild to think about like I don't
have any idea when this thing's getting
loaded, where is it getting loaded,
whatever. But I basically decide what if
I turn on the chip and I just try
glitching all along over time and see if
I can get myself JTAG access. Like a lot
of people do this to get JTAG access.
And I freaking got JTAG access. Like
that's wild. Um, I used 250 volts. The
probe was placed right there. Um, you
know, I have JTAG hooked up and I
managed to get JTAG access on this
thing. So, I mean, like my heart
freaking dropped. I was like, first of
all, I was like, thank God I'm done with
this goddamn project. Um, and so I'm
looking at the screen and it's almost
like a bit of disbelief. And so I go to
read the flash memory and when I do, all
I get are zeros.
um nothing comes out of it. And I
realized looking at the the manual a bit
more that yeah, I had managed to get
JTAG access, but the flash memory wasn't
unlocked. And so perhaps uh I could find
a secondary fault like to get in and
then to glitch again to get flash
access. But I was like, I don't know. I
mean, like some kind of double fault
setup. Like I don't know if I got that
in me to to figure that out.
But I would say on this one plus side is
um
I did manage to do it without 444 volts.
Um I didn't actually get access to what
I want, but I did cause the chip to, you
know, to do something with a pulse
that's below 444 volts.
Now
this so so the whole time I'm working on
the JTAG the whole time I'm doing
everything all I'm still like reading
everything I can find because I don't
know what attack vector might work. The
only thing I know is the UART's dead. I
can't use the UART but I'm still reading
about the canvas. And so I'm reading a
data sheet for a CAN controller chip.
And I see this thing called oneshot
mode. And so oneshot mode is basically
kind of what it sounds like. You can put
the controller into this mode. You tell
it to send one message and it doesn't
care whether there's an act or not. It
just sends one message. And I'm like,
that's exactly what I need to glitch
this freaking thing, right? Um, so I'm
looking at it, but the little cheapy
kind of USB CAN controller that I bought
off of Amazon doesn't support this mode.
I I'm looking I'm I'm using all the
tools, the Linux CAN tools. I'm trying
to do it, and there's not a mode I can
set. So, I'm like, I know it exists, but
this controller won't let me do it.
So, I end up in this kind of build
versus buy scenario, I would call it.
and I didn't want to actually build
anything, right? Like I would have just
bought a tool, but the challenge was the
tools were kind of expensive. I didn't
know how long it would take to get to
me. Um, this tool does supposedly does
support oneshot mode. Um, but the only
way I could figure that out was I was on
a like I was I was searching and I see a
forum post where a guy posts like, "Hey,
uh, did something happen? The latest
update? I can't do one shot anymore."
And they go, "Oh yeah, push this other
update." Um, and then I got to use some
unknown software they provide to to talk
to the thing. So, it's kind of feeling
like, man, I'm going to do a lot of work
even if I buy uh this tool and I'm not
even 100% sure that like it's going to
work. Or, um, I can just get an Arduino
from freaking MicroEnter down the road.
Um, cheapy 13 bucks, a $7 hat. That $7
hat is using the exact chip from the
data sheet I was reading. So, it's like
I know that supports one shot. Um, I'll
just have to write some code or whatever
to to actually make it do that. Um, so
that's what I did. It only ended up
taking maybe a day or or two. Most of it
was figuring out like how to load all
the CAN kind of register stuff in, you
know, in that chip. Um, but what I did
was just make an incredibly simple thing
where I just use two pins on the
Arduino. And if I hit one pin, it sends
a password message. If I hit another
pin, it sends the address and the size
of data that's going to come across. Um,
and so those are just hardcoded in it.
Um, that could probably like improve to
be like a serial interface where the
chip whisperer could kind of send these
commands to it. Um, but for what I
needed to do, it didn't need to be like,
you know, I just needed this. Um, and so
this is also on on GitHub. Um, this is,
you know, for 20 bucks, a super handy
tool if you need to do one shot kind of
stuff,
okay? But I shouldn't um
discount like the emotional roller
coaster uh that this was.
So um you know, it really is kind of
like screaming into the void. I found
myself walking around my neighborhood
just freaking staring at birds and trees
and wondering like, you know, what am I
doing with my life? Um and what the
hell's going on? and and that is uh
that's the reverse engineering process
for me. It might it's probably different
for everybody. Um but one of these days
I was walking around and I was listening
to uh to David Gogggins which you see in
the top right there. Um and he's not so
much a motivational speaker um as he you
know he's got a certain kind of message
um and that that message resonated with
me quite a bit.
And that's the reality. Like I, you
know, I was kind of like, you know, I'm
I'm coming up with all these excuses and
reasons and should I still be doing this
and all this stuff. And it really boils
down to like you just got to freaking
make a decision and do it. And so on on
that walk, I just decided I don't care
how long this takes me. I don't care if
you know if it's months or years. Like
I'm not stopping until I figure this
out. And if I don't ever figure it out
again, like if I don't ever figure it
out, I'm just disappearing. Like there's
no more riches. There's no more nothing.
That's it. Like it's work on this or
die. Like there's no there's no turning
back. Um and basically making that
decision,
two days later I figured it out. And so
it's amazing to me like how at least my
mind like how your mind is always
looking for escapes, you know, like how
can I get out of this thing? What can I
do to alleviate the pain? Um please make
it stop and and you have to just fight
through it. And when you make the
decision like that decision of like it's
this or never, um it's amazing like how
like the mode my my brain shifted into.
Now, obviously, I'd been working a lot
along the way, but um but that really uh
did it for me. So, here what I'm, you
know, I I'll explain a bit about the
canvas and what the challenge was. Um
but I'm curious in the chat, you guys
guess what do you think the voltage was,
um that actually did this thing, keeping
in mind that I had purchased the stuff
from Digi Key to go to a higher voltage
and and all these things. So after after
all was said and done, what do you think
the voltage was that it took to glitch
the canvas
and while I'm waiting for that what I'll
say is that the uh arbitration and
matching timing. So the challenge with
the canvas is with the UART it's very
specific like when you send a bite of
data to the processor
um that bite of data like it's sent
right over and then it's processed and
so it's very deterministic the timing of
when to glitch like you send the last
character of the password you glitch in
the same spot and you start sending the
next stuff with the CANB there's this
window of time because there's like a
separate engine running on this
processor that's receiving these CAN
messages is and then they go into a
buffer and then they're sitting in this
arbitration time and then it gets sent
to the processor. So it's not like you
hit the same spot every time when you do
a CAN attack. It's like you're doing the
CAN attack, the message stops at the
same place every time, but you're kind
of attacking in this window and it's
almost like statistically over some
number of hits you'll get to it. Um and
so for me it takes about 10 to 15
minutes and and it's repeatable. So
every 10 to 15 minutes I can glitch it
and it gets in over the canvas. Now here
we go. We got a zillion guesses. So I'm
going to read them. 180 volts, 250 128.
So I'm going to guess 444. That's a
freaking good guess considering how many
times I've put 444 in this presentation.
75 uh 48 volts. 5 volts. That's super
low. Um I don't think I can go below 50.
um high. Yeah, Pi was a great movie. Pi
is a freaking That's that black and
white movie that was playing in the
bottom right. It's called Pi, like the
symbol pi. That's worth watching.
60 volts. Freaking 60 volts was all it
took. Like after all the stressing and
agonizing over this. Um it was only 60
volts to freaking glitch this thing. And
that's also dependent on the size of the
coil, the number of the windings, all
these kinds of things. Um but you know,
it it wasn't the the freaking 444 that
it plugged me. It wasn't even 250. I
ended up lowering it way down because I
kept like it just kept not responding to
anything. And so I thought, well, maybe
it's too high. Like it didn't seem right
to me. Like I was pegged at 250 for all
my tests, which is the same with the
JTAG you saw me do. But as I lowered it
more and more, I started getting better
and better results. And then at 60
volts, like my loop just runs 60 and
when it gets to 61, it goes right back
to 60. Um, yeah, at 60 it was super
super repeatable. Obviously for me
that's everything related to my setup
and how it was, but it definitely wasn't
a high voltage.
Now, but in the back of my mind, all
I've done is basically get it to respond
to the second message. So, uh, at this
point, I send the password.
I then glitch it. I send the second
message, which is the address and the
amount of data. And if it responds to
that message, it basically means I found
a glitch that's allowing me to get into
that boot module. But that's all like
there's no no firmware, nothing's coming
because of this. So in the back of my
head is that freaking J-TAG experiment,
right, where I did get in, but then I
read zeros out of the flash. So still,
I'm not like super confident that I've
got something. I'm I'm happy that I did
manage to get this canvas thing working,
but you know, it's it's I'm not popping
bottles at this point. let's put it that
way.
Um, now this is what's in Colin's paper.
Um, that they had to basically create a
second stage bootloader to validate
access. Um, which is like reading the
shadow memory, which is this part in
that chip, you know, extracting all the
flash and everything else. Now, Colin
doesn't share this second stage
bootloader. I'm not sure why they didn't
post that. Um, I guess technically you
don't need to for that paper, you know,
to kind of like for you to test the
premise of that paper, which is
glitching and seeing it respond to the
second message, but it'd be freaking
nice. Um, you know, like for anyone else
that wants to do an attack like this.
Um, it's not top secret information. Um,
and it's I'll tell you what, it's
freaking damn hard to do. Um, and so so
yeah, so even though I had this access,
I still had a freaking road ahead of me.
And the challenge was the road ahead of
me I could not solve with just the one
board that I have.
I need a development board because like
how could I code up an entire second
stage bootloadader using the only board
with the only information I need to
extract and the only way to load the
code would be to like glitch it for 15
minutes and then try to put on my code
that I'm writing. Like I'm not a like a
mega software developer. So, like I'm an
iterative software developer. Like I'm
like, does it work? Run. Does it work?
Run. Does it work? Run. Um, and so I
need, you know, some kind of development
board. But these freaking development
boards for these things are expensive as
hell. Like, it's almost two grand for
this MPC development board. And I'm
like, dude, I'm already losing my ass
here um on the quote quoted amount for
the job. So, uh, I'm not dropping two
grand on a development board that's
going to sit in a bin with the other
development boards when I'm done with
it.
But I'm also reading all kinds of car
hacking forums the entire time I'm doing
this. And I'm scanning for any I mean,
I'm looking for knowledge from anywhere.
I don't care where it comes from. Like,
anything that might give me a hint on
what to do, how to do it, whatever.
Um, and so what I see is that there's
these other GM ECUs that are freaking
dirt cheap, like 30 bucks, you know, on
the lefth hand side, which are the E39A.
I mean, they're basically giving those
away. Um, you can't even get like
Starbucks for that price. Uh, or the E39
itself, which is $64.95 on the right.
Now, the difference between these two is
that the E39
has on it when you look at the board an
MPC 5566.
These E39A's, most of them have this SGM
PPC whatever chip. Um, both made by the
same manufacturer, but I'm like, is that
the same chip? You know, like if I build
an attack for this SGM PPPC thing, like
would it even work? Um, but I came
across some posts on these forums and
people were speculating that this SGM
PPC chip really just is an MPC 5566.
Um, no one had confirmed it or whatever,
but they kind of like I can access it
the same way and everything. Um, and so
I thought, okay, like you know, I'll
I'll just give it a go. So I bought all
of them. Like I bought, you know, all
the E39A you saw there and the E39. I
thought like this is cheap enough like
and I'm gonna have to destroy one or two
anyways to figure out what I need to
figure out.
Um but it turns out like some of these
tuning boards um they actually give you
a lot of the information you need
because they sell tuning tools to
connect into these. So there's pictures
of the lids popped. You can look at the
circuit board. They show you where the
canvas connections are, where you need
to apply power. Um, they show you where
the boot pins are that you need to set
to put it into boot mode. So, it's like
as far as building a development board
goes, like this is pretty freaking
sweet. Um, I kind of have the
information I need to connect it up and
put it into this bootloader mode. I know
where to connect all the canvas pins.
So, I don't even need to do the drag
method of the the wire across the board
or or anything. It's kind of like here's
everything I need to know to turn this
thing into a development board.
So, the first thing I did when I got one
of these E39AS is I was like, well, I
have fuming nitric acid, right? Um, I
made this um as part of my talk last
year at Hardware IO and you can use
fuming nitric acid to decap microchips.
So, I thought like how about we just
settle the the debate, right? Is this
SGM chip, what is it? So, I put some
acid on there. Um, I ate through the top
and everything. and I threw it under the
microscope and sure enough, right on the
bottom right of that chip there is
MPC5566.
So I was like, sweet. This is probably
just some custom labeling for GM. Maybe
it's a, you know, some something they
did to just say, okay, this is GM
specific part. Maybe they don't rev the
silicon. Who knows? Um, but they created
this specific part number for them to
use on their their board, but it's just
basically an MPC 5.566. So then I had
some comfort. I'm like, okay, I can
really try working on these boards and
building attacks on them and writing my
code and know that it's going to work
across to the other uh the other boards.
Now, I ended up with a bit of a problem.
Um, and that problem is that these
boards are locked. Like, they have a
password on them. Um, and so I can't
actually access it over the canvas to
write my code. Even though I have a
glitch right now that will basically
allow me to uh, you know, get past the
password and send the next part, I need
to basically write this secondary
bootloader. It's going to take me
hundreds, probably at least high tens,
maybe low, low hundreds of iterations of
compiling and running. um just that's
what I'm thinking in my head to actually
get this to work. And so I can't be on a
15minute load cycle every time um and be
not sure. So like I need the password
for this thing in order to just expedite
the the development process.
So on one of the forums I was on, I
remember seeing this post and this post
was this guy had figured out if you send
him a picture. So like this picture I
have here is the picture from my board.
If you send him that picture, he can
take those numbers and he's got some
algorithm or something he runs. He can
turn it into the code that gets you
access. Um, and it it appeared um from
my kind of looking that he was he was
based out of Russia. Um, and so I was
like, how can I track this person down
and see if they'll do this for me? They
they seem pretty open in this forum to
doing it. So, these are my messages. I
went on uh Telegram and I found them. I
reached out to them. I said, "Hey, I'm
trying to do this on an E39A." Um, I had
been, you know, trying to use a PE
microp programmer.
um you know, would you be able to
calculate this code for me? I'm trying
to appeal to the technical side of of
this person because I've read like every
single forum post they had ever posted
and I could see, you know, they're very
technically oriented and minded. So,
like, you know, will they, you know,
give me the homie hookup on this thing?
And so, boom, immediately I'll calculate
the password for money, 50 bucks crypto.
And I'm like, damn. like geopolitically,
do I send 50 bucks to Russia? Um, is
that a problem even? Um, you know, it's
it kind of like I kind of just hate
paying for stuff like this honestly cuz
it's like you never really know even are
you going to get something or not. Um,
and so I thought like well I'm still not
convinced though that like I've done a
good enough job. So I go, hey, let me
give this person something of value. So,
I say, "Hey, I noticed on these message
boards, everyone was speculating about
this chip. Um, but I actually decapped
it and I determined that it's an MPC
5566." And I just thought like, you
know, you're the kind of person that
would want to know this information.
And so, boom, says, "I'll calculate it
for you for free." And I was like,
"Sweet." Um, I send the picture, they
send me the code. That is the actual
code that I use to access mine. Um, and
then after that started chatting a ton
about hacking all other kind of ECUs and
I was like, "Oh my god, I'm going to get
freaking sucked into this ECU hacking
world." Um, this is what Colin talked
about. Colin published some of this
stuff. Colin Ollin and then like if you
look at any of his web pages now, he's
like, "If you're a tuner, do not talk to
me." Um, because I think the entire
tuning world was like descended upon
Colin to uh, you know, get uh, more
information. Um, and so this guy was
very interesting. and he's working on
all kinds of uh crazy stuff, but I was
like, you know, I'm just I'm just trying
to do this thing and I I really
appreciate you hooking me up.
So, uh I'm not going to go through all
the code here. This is code warrior
that's actually used to write this
secondary bootloader. But what I tell
I'll tell you about is kind of the
things that um were very
uh you know, kind of like hurdles that I
I went through. Um, and so the first,
you know, the first program is like a
hello world for an embedded device is I
just wanted to cause a pin to go high
and low, you know, blink an LED
basically. So I'm watching it on the
oscilloscope. That was the that was
incredibly hard. Um, because when you
build this bootloadader kind of code, it
doesn't run the same way standard code
would run that would compile and get
loaded into flash. Um, it gets loaded
into some segment of RAM and then told
to jump there and execute. So, it has to
initialize all kinds of stuff on its
own. Um, and so even the the files that
are there, you have to add extra files
into the the link order. Um, all this
kind of stuff to get this to actually
work. This is the link order right here.
You had to put like this uh start file
at the very beginning of the link order.
You had to tweak all kinds of stuff with
the freaking uh the the definition file.
You have to define all your memory
segments, where you want to put things,
the length of those segments, uh all
kinds of crap to get it to work, just to
get that freaking blinking light um test
code to work. Once I got that to work,
um then it was kind of like, okay, can I
send a CAN message? That's its own set
of crap you have to do. The board
initializes at like a 400 kilobit uh CAN
rate, but all the sample code is for
like 500 kilobit. So you have to
calculate a bunch of crap um of how to
like these CAN messages. What's this
segment length and that segment length
and all this other stuff? Um but then I
was able to transmit a CAN message back
to myself. Um then I tried to read some
of the flash memory and send that over
the canvas which was I was just going to
read the password section because I know
what the password is. I'm using it to
access it. If I can read that section
from flash and the same password comes
back, then I know I've actually um
figured that part out. I got that which
was good news. Um and then I have to
read the entire flash from the chip and
dump that out. Um and so these are the
the kind of programs you'll see that on
my GitHub. All of this is there. All of
these sample programs um are there. So
if you want to try, you know, running
any of this stuff, doing things with it,
like you have all the code and all the
the pain that it took to figure it out.
Now, um, one of the things, one of the
big hurdles was, um, this chip uses
like, uh, it has like some error
correcting ECC thing going on with the
memory. So basically, if you don't
initialize all of the memory that the
chip's going to use, so like the code
you're sending, um, any stack space,
anything else, this block of memory, it
will fail an ECC check of its own memory
and it just never runs. So for the
longest time, I was like, I'm sending
code there that probably should have run
and nothing was happening. It's because
I wasn't initializing like the RAM
space, the stack space, the full kind of
code block that this thing's going to
make use of. Um, and so the way I ended
up doing that was I couldn't I I don't
say I couldn't I yeah, I guess I
couldn't figure out how to do it easily
inside of my code itself. So basically
to have the chip when it starts from its
kind of bootloadader spot initialize all
of its own internal memory that it was
going to use. Um, so I thought like well
I don't really need to do that. like
I'll just basically make it where when I
send the program to the chip, I build a
big file with all zeros and then I load
my code in at the top of that little
file right there and I send the whole
block of essentially initialized memory
plus my code. Um, and so that's what I
do here. I I kind of initialize this
block um loader bytes, you know, of of
data. I load my code into the beginning
of that where it would live in memory
and then I send the whole thing. Um, and
so then it's easy enough uh to get the
code there.
Let's see if I missed anything on that.
I think that's it.
So, the day of the attack, this is what
it looked like. Um, which is like, do
not breathe on this wrong. Um,
definitely do not let the dog in. Um,
nothing, nobody should walk near these
wires. Um, even you see how the the chip
the the pico EMP is kind of sitting
above there. If the temperature in the
room changed from evening to morning
like everything would probably flex a
tiny bit and I would have to readjust to
get this attack to work. So this is it
working. This is what a real attack
looks like. You know, it's like you're
you're just in the middle of it and you
you get it to work. So if your stuff
looks like this, if it looks like a
freaking hot mess, you're on the right
path. like this is just what real kind
of hacking looks like. You know, the
pictures, the YouTube videos, all that
stuff. That's us cleaning it up after
the fact uh to try to make it like where
we can actually explain what the hell's
going on because the reality is it it
looks like this.
Now, I did make a clean version for you
so that I can kind of explain what it is
so that if you want to replicate this
attack, um you can, you know, you can do
it. So I'll spend a little time here and
explain it. So the devices we have in
the picture. Um on the far left, that
board with the two little gold
connection connectors is a chip
whisperer.
It's kind of the conductor of this
thing. It's orchestrating the entire
attack. Now what is going to the chip
whisperer from the main processor is the
reset line because I need to reset this
board kind of between each attack. the
clock line so I can monitor it to see
like how's the attack doing from that
kind of image I showed before and then
down to the bottom a couple of triggers
are going over to our Arduino board. Um
so the first part of this attack is to
use that Arduino board. So it's to reset
the main processor in the middle then
use the Arduino board to send our first
message.
We send our first message and then the
chip whisperer tells the pico EMP up top
that I'm holding to send the pulse.
Okay? And so we're in a loop and we're
trying to send pulses at different
places. We send the pulse. We then send
another control line over to the Arduino
to send the second message which is um
you know the the kind of the the address
in memory we want to load it and how
much data we're going to send it.
if we get a response from that message.
So, the way we get the response is that
little CAN uh bus USB thing in the
bottom right that's going over to our uh
our computer um our little uh TRS uh
100. Um if if the the computer sees that
response to that message, then over that
same canvas line, it sends all the code
into our our place that we want to run
our bootloader kind of firmware
extraction code. Now, there's a couple
other devices. The one that's right
above where it says clock is another
CANbus decoder. So what I'm doing is
when I send the first message from the
Arduino to the processor, I watch that
message go across the wire and I feed
that back to the chip whisper. That's
how it's getting its timing. That's how
it knows when to send it. So it's
actually seeing the message go across
the wire. It's starting its timer. Timer
gets to a certain point, sends the
electromagnetic pulse, then the the
Arduino sends the next message. Um, I
also have a little relay that's labeled
power right above that. That's if like
something goes completely sideways with
the test setup. Like, so if that clock
line just falls low and dies, I know I
need to power cycle the board. Now, I
don't power cycle the board every time
because time is like your your greatest
enemy in these kinds of things. um you
know if you're maybe you have to do
hundreds or thousands of glitches before
you get a successful one. So you're
always trying to shrink the amount of
time between glitches to the millisecond
level if possible so that you can do a
lot of glitches and not take a lot of
time. Um so I only power cycle the board
when I know I'm in a state I need to
power cycle it otherwise I just reset
it. Um, you know, you have the the Pico
EMP also has a USB line to the computer
and the the chip whisperer has a USB
line to the computer. Those are kind of
controlling all the other functions
there like on the Pico EMP to adjust the
voltage and everything like that. Um,
and so that's the the kind of the whole
attack in a nutshell. And when it works,
you get happy customer. Um, happy
customer gets their code um and they're
off and running doing um whatever they
want to do with that code.
Now a little bit on the data itself. So
the data when I get it to come out over
the canvas. So if you run this attack,
if you look at the code, um what I do is
I just use different arbitration ids on
the canvas to specify what data is being
sent. So I send CAN messages at 100 and
100 is dumping the the boot the boot
access module code itself. So to maybe
try reverse engineering that and saying
like, "Hey, can we find some other
vulnerability?" When I get to the end of
that code space, I send a 101 as the
arbitration ID. And so this little
Python, you know, script just sees 101
and it goes, "Okay, I'm all done with
that." It writes the data. Um, and then
it it exits out of that. It goes to the
next part. The next part is waiting for
200 messages. That's the shadow area of
the flash where the password of the
board is contained. Um, and then when
it's done, a 2011. And then the same for
the main flash. So the entire flash of
the chip comes out as 300. When it's all
done, you get a 301.
Now, one thing I should say about
extracting the flash is that my code,
the code you'll see on GitHub, doesn't
deal um it doesn't handle the case where
the flash is corrupted. So, if some part
of your flash memory is corrupted and
there's a read failure, um I won't I I
basically just crap out like the thing
just crashes. Um luckily on the board
that I needed to extract the flash from,
there were no flash errors. So, it
extracted no problem. On the board I
bought off of eBay, there was a flash
error, which is probably why it was on
eBay for 25 bucks. Um so, I I just kind
of incremented past the memory and then
continued and made sure my code worked.
um that would be an opportunity for
improvement in that code. Um I didn't I
didn't know how to handle that case and
I figured why even work on it if it if
it works to dump the code. That's my
only goal. And so it did. The cool thing
is now that this code exists, you could
just buy some $25 board off of eBay. You
don't need the Russian homie hookup um
to get the password because you have the
bootloadader. You could just build the
glitch setup. you could glitch it once,
get it to extract its password here, and
then you would have a development board.
Um, and so, but I didn't have this code
beforehand, so I had to I had to go the
other route.
Um, now, like I said, it's called NPC
5566 tools. It includes the oneshot
stuff for the Arduino. It includes all
the boot access mode applications, boot
access module applications. So, all the
different iterations that I went through
are all there. I even include what I
call flex can dumper. Um, which was the
final binary file that I loaded that
worked. So, if you can't get the stuff
to compile or whatever, like that's the
one like that's the one I load that
outputs it in that format that I talked
about. Um, and then my entire Jupyter
notebook and Jupiter is what is used.
It's kind of like a big Python notebook
to control the chip whisper and
everything else. Um, so that's all
there. Um,
yeah. So, just a fiveday project. Uh,
one of the comments. So, this actually
took like 65 days. Um, all said and
done. And I'm talking every day, like
just weekends, everything. All I was
doing was this. You can see that the
window if you look at my YouTube channel
of like no publishing for an incredibly
long period of time. That's this
project. Um, I just literally I could
not get my brain to do anything except
obsess over this. Um, so it's costly to
take on a project like that because it
has lots of other impacts even if you
know even if the money was all right.
Um, there's a question how high is the
chance you would corrupt your flash with
the glitching? Um, I didn't see any
corrupted flash with it. Um, but on some
voltage glitching specifically to this
zeroday attack you see that I did on the
SAM 4C32 which is on my YouTube channel.
That one I was able to voltage glitch it
and corrupt flash with like a long
enough voltage glitch at the right
point. So, it's not without danger when
you do this, but out of all the
thousands and thousands of whatever that
I did, I didn't see any um corruption of
flash. But yeah, it's not it's not
without danger for sure. Like, you know,
you you really got to be uh kind of
planning these things out.
Now, the interesting thing is the SAM
4C32
only took me two days to figure out. So,
you contrast this, which is on my
channel, with the 65 days of the MPC
5566, this thing, I already knew I
needed to design a custom board. I
already knew I needed to like control
everything. And literally from the start
of trying to attack this thing to
getting an attack that let me pass the
lock mechanism where I could extract the
flash and get um JTAG access on that
chip was 2 days. Um and so that two days
was possible because of the 65 days of
suffering basically um because I knew
all the things. I had extreme confidence
in my ability to do it. And the video
that came out prior to this I had so
much confidence I actually just said in
that video like I'm going to extract the
memory from this chip. like it was a
foregone conclusion in my mind that I
would figure this out after the struggle
of the last thing. Um, and I had my I
had my boy up there with the
motivational messages in case I uh in
case I didn't get it done.
Now, um, this will conclude it. Um
there's some I I like reading books
about art I would say and and somehow
the the struggle of creating art and the
struggle of reverse engineering it feels
like there's a lot of parallels to me
and so I saw this quote which was it
basically starts that you know creating
art precipitates self-doubt but to me
it's like reverse engineering for me I
mean it's like I question everything
about my life when I work on this
stirring deep waters that lay between
what you know you should be and what you
fear you might be. Um, and yeah, that
that just really hits home for me. Um,
so I'll I'll take a look at the uh the
questions. I'll see if there's uh
anything there that you got that I
didn't cover. If you have any other kind
of questions, feel free to hit me with
them. Um, and I'll answer them and I'll
hang around a bit. Otherwise, this is
the end. Um, and thanks uh thanks for
joining and commenting while uh while I
was doing it.